and next up
we are joined by an american artist
who's
thinking of new rituals
please welcome
the creative director of jump star
george farandi
as an artist who spent most of my life
in east coast cities i never really saw
the stars until i spent some time in the
mountains where the night sky was so
spectacular i bought a book by h.a and
margaret ray to help me understand what
i was seeing
in it i learned about axial precession
a very slow wobble in earth's rotation
that means
while our polar axis currently points to
polaris in a thousand years it will
point to another star
in other words our literal and
figurative guiding light our north star
which has come to symbolize the single
thing that never changes will change
but of course it will
the universe is change
what i want to know is how will we
commemorate that change
we have a huge party every time the
earth makes one rotation around the sun
fancy clothes sparkly drinks we lament
the past predict the future
for an event that happens every year
surely there will be an unforgettable
celebration to acknowledge the star that
for centuries led ships to shore and
enslaved people to freedom
who will write the songs for that
occasion will the un organize a
committee will nasa
who will plan the party to say goodbye
to our north star and when will they
start
which begs the question what if it's us
and what if we start now
and this is the premise of jumpstart
a multi-disciplinary initiative that
brings artists musicians and scientists
together with communities to invent
traditions that can be passed through
the generations to say goodbye to
polaris and hello to gamma c phi
the whole project is named in honor of
annie jump cannon the remarkable def
harford astronomer who established our
star classification system which was
officially adopted 100 years ago this
week
and the way it works is through a series
of dream storming workshops we call
constellates
each consulate is dedicated to
researching and inventing one aspect of
future culture
a song a healing ceremony a celebratory
snack
for our dance consulate in kansas for
example
local performers working in a range of
styles each contributed a gesture that
our choreographer then incorporated into
an experimental version of a barn dance
which is a style beloved in that
particular region
for our future foods consulate our
climatologist explains how climate
change will affect what agriculture will
be viable in the region in a thousand
years
and then participants work with local
chefs to invent new recipes using those
ingredients like cricket flour to make
chocolate chip cookies
i've been researching all the stars that
are in our cycle of future north stars
and have developed characters for each
of them based on how they're described
by various cultures through history
and then with communities around the
country i'm designing and building
ceremonial sculptures to represent these
future north stars
using a technique traditional in a
japanese festival called nabuta which
was itself once a star festival
the sculptures have lightweight wooden
armatures and wire frames with paper
skins and they're illuminated from the
inside clockwise from the left is deneb
the indestructibles theta buddhist aka
boots fubin and vega
and they're all designed to be danced by
teams of community participants we call
dark matter since dark matter is what
holds up the stars here we have polaris
gamma sipha rock bogathi shemalai
alfawares and alderaan
and they were all to be part of
jumpstar's inaugural ceremony in kansas
but they haven't had the premiere yet a
few hours after our rehearsal and these
photos a tornado destroyed the
surrounding tents somehow our tent and
the very fragile paper sculpture
survived unscathed but only the dark
matter volunteers have ever seen them in
person
so we're still inventing the celebration
and wondering where the first ever
jumpstart ceremony will be
but we're not wondering why it's
important it can be easier to imagine
apocalypse than to look to the future
with hope
but as the long now community knows
our visions for the future
are the very tools that will help us
build it
jumpstart offers the promise of a party
and the celestial moment as playful
strategies for forging those tools with
the questions
what do we need to repair and prepare in
the present before we can host the
future
how do we get our house in order before
the holiday
it lets us look forward with love to the
resilience of civilizations of the
future
take action to ensure them a livable
world
and plan the party that will celebrate
their survival
thank you so much for listening and
thank you to the long now for presenting
thank you george when you were
creating this ritual
what are some of the ideas that you
discarded
oh my gosh
well
the the whole project kind of grows from
the inside out
and so
what makes it
to the table is what has
meaning to the people in the room
so
what what i select or discard isn't as
important as kind of what we come to
by consensus in each of the communities
all right well thank you for being with
us today george